so excited to be here thank you so much
for having me
i'm so excited to talk to you i remember
the first time i met you was because i
went to your show as an audience member
there's really nothing more exciting
than
doing a whole show and then learning
after the fact that drew barrymore was
sitting there the whole time and then
you're like
what what just happened and then
since then it's just been a blossoming
relationship and i'm grateful to you
i am too and i am glad because we are
getting to know each other and
um i was so excited to learn your design
junkie
oh i love it i love decorating stuff
i mean i'm not i like it i don't i don't
really know too much about it but i love
it i love looking at interiors like i
love
to walk down the street at night when
everybody's lights are on in their home
and
like i like to look inside their
apartments and houses
um it's it's a healthy stocking of homes
yes
gentle stocking um i like a gentle
stocking
i feel like i'm a gentle stalker um
have you used any of your like at-home
time um like this past year to spruce
things up where are you at and design
what are you putting around you
what's your aesthetic and actionability
on it all
sure we definitely we actually bought a
house
prior to the pandemic and so we've been
kind of putting it together
slowly over time and it's been really
fun i
love my house now so much i i do enjoy
it
i love a little i love a little
feathered nest and we built a garden in
the backyard so we're
we spent the whole summer eating too
many tomatoes
all that stuff all that good stuff all
that home stuff that is like the dream
did you think when like
your younger self existed on the planet
that you would ever have like
family cozy kitchen and like gorging on
tomatoes
absolutely not no it just wasn't even no
it was
it was not something i ever thought was
possible so it's been it's been
it's been i think really a godsend
during the pandemic to be to have a
place where we
can gather and i'm really uh grateful
for that
i can't thinking lately that growing up
is not overrated it's kind of awesome
yeah i feel like i'm kind of at the
height of my
powers as a human and i think it only
gets better i'm kind of looking forward
to my 80s that's when i'm going to start
wearing a bikini
i'm just going to like hit the beaches
of ibiza
and do all kinds of stuff i never did
and you do have like a beautiful family
i always admire couples who like work
together and collaborate that's such a
fantasy to me
you know for many years you guys work
together oh there you are
yeah there we are together we yeah we i
mean we've worked together since
so we've been together for about 24
years now
i can't ever remember how long we've
been married but it's like around 20
years
that's awful i'm really bad at dates and
stuff
but like around 20 years and we have
three kids and we've just
always collaborated the only thing
that's changed about us collaborating is
that the scale has changed
so now people actually watch the
collaborations that we make
as opposed to just us but um and we're
all better off
for it but how's your power designing
together
okay so we were pulling all the threads
of this house together and jason
has he likes to think like he imagines
for himself that he doesn't have any
opinion and anything is fine with him
but then when it comes time to actually
put the thing into the house
he is extremely opinionated like on the
day that it goes in so
we had a set of stairs they were really
slippery they were wood stairs and i was
like jason i'm going to put carpet on
these stairs so i don't fall down and
like break my neck and he was like
yeah whatever i don't care i didn't even
care and then the day they
brought the carpet to put it in he was
like i don't want car what are we doing
carpet for
i don't want a carpet what are we in
carpet for we're not we're not going to
fall down the stairs i'm like jason you
can't say
when they're installing the carpet no
longer you have to decide
i'm like you have to talk to me about it
in advance and then we can decide
together
now um as the last question i just want
to ask like if you had
um like a design aesthetic
or you have a designer or like
a company that encompasses you or
multi-like what would be a little
samantha bee home mood board would it be
a little of this magazine
a little of that store a little of that
era
yeah i think it's like kind of woodsy i
think it's like a little bit of
maybe like a little bit of bringing
nature inside but not
too much like i love like a wallpaper
that has creatures on it or i love
you know i like it i like lots of i like
wood i like wood inside
and a little bit neutral with you know
remember like
when ac dc would play all the time
they'd be like the guitarist has to go
to a white room
and calm down for three hours after
every concert he plays that's how i feel
in my house i'm like
yeah i gotta like be in a place where i
can just like calm down
but also have a couple of cute things to
look at
i did not know that i'm so caught up in
the detail of this guy had to go sit in
a white room
no that's i don't know if that's true
but that was what i was told when i was
girl when i was like growing up and
listening to ac dc they were like
yeah angus has to go to a white cupboard
somewhere i mean
and he went in his little like school
boy outfit
yeah he's like take his tie off and he
just has to sit there and breathe
and i honestly that's how i think of my
living room
ridiculous i don't know why
um i love everything about that answer
so much
that i want to just continue to keep
unpacking it throughout my day and carry
it with me
samantha bee full frontal airs
wednesdays at 10 30
9 30 central on tbs in its sixth season
it's the best show ever and you are the
best
[Music]